[Music]
hey you guys it's our thanksgiving
matinee show yeah
why didn't we do this one on
thanksgiving because i'm gonna eat on
thanksgiving we don't usually stream on
thanksgiving day it's like i kind of
wanted a day off you know
i thought that would have been nice it's
good but uh you know and honestly and i
actually recorded a review of pilgrim
yeah the hulu into the dark thanksgiving
movie that i'm gonna put up on
thanksgiving
but it's just you know i didn't know
about that one yeah i didn't like i said
i wanted a day off i didn't necessarily
want to like have to stream on the
holiday because i figured people
wouldn't be watching it anyway okay
uh yeah somebody uh danny rolling
ghostway said about uh blood rage yeah
that's another one we have to do and i
think shutter just added that one we
might have to wait till next
thanksgiving though
unless we could do like extra one we're
doing two movies today
yeah thanks killing so david june sent
us this it was like it's a little box
set yeah and it has the first one and it
has uh thanks killing three which you
would think is the third one
but it's actually the sequel yeah
they're always [ __ ] spinning they're
spending the whole time looking for
[ __ ] part two yeah we'll kind of get
into that but yeah so uh david june also
wanted me to mention that his sister
crystal was a producer on the third one
okay yeah
it was a good movie it was actually it
scaled up quite nicely it's not the same
kind of movie it's it's very different
but it's still good it's [ __ ] it's an
acid trip
yeah i would even argue that the third
well this second one that's called
thanks killing three is like not even
really a horror movie it's barely a
horror movie no yeah it's almost kind of
like a weird
it's kind of like something you'd see on
adult swim and like that you would kind
of like get high and watch um and it's
also a little bit of a jim henson's
paradise
like kind of like the dark crystal or
labyrinth yeah with fraggle rock mixed
up
like there was there was something it's
pretty weird there's some gore in there
and some stuff that's you know with the
turkeys it's a [ __ ] trip
it got so convoluted the second one or
part three
which is the second one
um
i had a hard time keeping track of it
you you you'd have to watch this two or
three times i think to catch everything
yeah i mean like if i actually said like
what the plot was which i probably will
at some point i think people would think
that i was making it up yeah it's all
kinds of certainly not making it up this
let's start off with the first one then
yeah the first one now the first one
came out of 2008 and uh very proudly
they put it right on the front of the
dvd and everything yeah uh that this
costs 3 500 to make yeah and it's a tits
within the first 10 for
the first second for a second yeah
exactly
that's right they're warning boobs in
the first second it says tits in the
first second it has some she's retired
porn star in there now she was uh wanda
lust wanda lust yeah
just starts off with her in the in a
pilgrimage with her titties [ __ ]
hanging out just running and she's being
chased by something and she turns around
you see it's a big old [ __ ] it's not
even a big old turkey it's just a turkey
with a hatchet kills her nice [ __ ]
it's got real [ __ ] um
the humor in it is good it's funny
it's fun it kind of like i feel like it
sort of straddles the line between
self-awareness and also being like the
humor is kind of like obnoxious and like
punny
but
because they're kind of aware of it and
they're kind of making fun of it
it's kind of like i said it's really
really hard to like do a bad movie on
purpose yeah um and i think this one
like
mostly succeeds i mean some of the humor
falls flat but i think it like kind of
meant it took a while for the movie to
kind of spool up yeah
the first it was it started off with the
bag some titties you know like what
you're gonna do with it
and then it takes a while for it to kind
of catch it stride then it starts doing
some [ __ ] that's [ __ ] hilarious like
between the two friends and the one the
second dude dies and his first friend is
[ __ ] pulling him up to heaven there
ain't no turkey's up here just okay now
that [ __ ] was funny she was but she was
[ __ ]
it was um
it was it was good i liked it it was um
it is entertaining let's say it's not
good it's entertaining which that's not
it wasn't meant to be good it wasn't
meant to be good yeah just i mean
considering it only cost thirty five
hundred dollars yeah um it doesn't look
too bad for like being thirty five
hundred and some of the gore effects and
stuff like that are actually pretty good
i don't think i could do that for thirty
five hundred dollars i don't think i
could either to be honest with you like
i said i'm not like a special effects
person or a particularly uh competent
camera person yeah but i mean yeah not
bad for 3 500 and like i said if you
don't have a lot of money then this is
probably the route that you want to go
where you just kind of have to make it
like funny gory lots of nudity right
[ __ ] like that and a ridiculous premise
yeah just lean into it and that's what
they did and um also like i said it's
kind of making fun of itself too because
it's essentially a slasher movie about a
killer turkey
that can talk and the there's a
backstory behind it which is told in
like a nice little animation sequence
yeah of i guess it was like a native
american shaman
and he was like pissed off at being
disrespected by a white dude so all of
the like white people subsequently are
now kind of like cursed like the
turkey's gonna come back
every 505 years yeah to [ __ ] with
everybody even though
the beginning part with the with the
titty pilgrim yeah
titty pilgrim yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah go to the biker bar and
we'll call you there
but yeah so the the first part with
teddy pilgrim took place in 1621 quote
unquote the olden days yeah uh but then
the turkey is supposed to come back
every 505 years 505 years would be 2 000
uh 125 so they're so they can't math but
that's okay maybe that was like part of
the joke i'm not really sure uh well
like i said it's it's kind of hard to
say but uh but yeah so you have that and
then it jumps ahead and then you have
like five really stereotypical kind of
like you know what i mean there's like
the jock there's
the nice girl there's the [ __ ] girl
the fat party animal and the nerd
yeah um so you have those five types who
in real life would never hang out
together but they do that in horror
movies all the time so that's what
they're lampooning and they're going
home for thanksgiving and then their car
breaks down of course and now they're
like trapped in the woods and they're
just gonna party in the woods whoo it's
thanksgiving break
and so they're camping out in the woods
right where
this uh supposed thing happened with the
turkey the turkey the killer turkey
whose name is just turkey yeah i can't
believe we're talking about this this
like well what what are we gonna do just
like stay here
we're talking about it now i think it's
funny it's just funny
no i'm not saying don't talk about it
yeah i'm just going to sit here i can't
believe we're talking about it because i
saw these movies and then
but that's what that's the fun like
talking about the movies yeah so
so what happens in this movie there's
all kind of crazy [ __ ] happening
um there is let's see um
there's a guy who inexplicably like uh
when turkey because that's just his name
but i think it's t-u-r-k-i-e
that's his name is turkey with an i.e
instead of an e-y
so he's trying to get into town to kill
the kids or their parents or whatever i
don't know what to do what he's doing
he's just killing everybody and um
he's like hitchhiking
or something or he's just like on the
side of the road and this random dude
just stops the car to pick him up
and he's basically like a turkey and
he's just like not like oh my god a
talking turkey he's just like ooh hot a
talking turkey and then he gets in the
car and he's just gonna [ __ ] the turkey
well he says no he he he stopped oh ass
gas or grass yeah he goes ass gas or
grass
[ __ ] turkey gets in and it doesn't
answer but you know the [ __ ] dude's
just looking at the circus like i'm
gonna [ __ ] this turkey
well he starts unbuttoning his pants
[Laughter]
that turkey [ __ ] blows his head off
with a shotgun
the turkey does stuff it's never
explained how could the turkey this big
carry a shotgun a full-length shot dude
what's he called what's he holding it
with
you don't ever really see it and that's
part of the that's part of the yeah
he's like he's a
shaman made him how does a damn turkey
hit you with axe
that it's not explained it just you just
it just happens yeah it just happens
well how does the turkey talk you're
right it's all just the brilliance of
the movie how does a turkey cut
somebody's face off and put it on its
face and fool everything that was my
favorite part actually daughter
she thought that that was her dad that
was my favorite part yeah there's all
kinds of ridiculous [ __ ] happening well
the whole part that whole sequence
because the nice girl's dad is the
sheriff
that guy is hilarious too like he's just
he has a fake mustache on and he's just
like doing this over-the-top southern
accent and it's hilarious and even
before like any of the turkey
shenanigans um he's having a fight with
like his wife who i presume is the
second wife because she calls it the
step mom later who uh he takes a a sip
of the coffee and he spits it out he's
like this coffee tastes like [ __ ] what'd
you do take a dump in the pot and she's
like yeah i did i want a divorce yeah
you can see it in there
and then he's like sends it to the phone
well your stepmom left yeah you know
what i mean it's just so it's that kind
of thing and then like turkey comes to
the door
and he thinks that it's a [ __ ]
because the turkey can talk and so the
turkey is like saying that he's friends
with her with the daughter
and he just said oh i didn't know that
that she had a friend that was a [ __ ]
or whatever come on in and he's also
inexplicably in a turkey costume i can't
remember why he has a turkey costume on
did it have something i don't remember
it doesn't matter it didn't matter but
he's in a turkey costume yeah and then
so turkey kills the dad and takes off
his face and wears his face and
obviously even though this is a turkey
sized turkey yeah wearing a person's
face that is really really small yeah he
comes to the door
and everybody and talks his way and
talks to like their dad and everyone's
just kind of like dad he's like you look
kind of different dad oh you cut your
hair
that was my favorite that was actually i
don't know if that was my maybe that was
my second favorite part because my
actual favorite part
is when
the fat guy
gets killed by eating like a cartoon
turkey
which is somehow magically also turkey
yeah he comes out there and he shoots
his way out of his stomach
and then like when he dies like him and
the nerd
who i guess we're like best friends like
and then there's this big long montage
of like their friend with like them
eating ice cream and skipping through a
field holding hands and stuff like that
and then the fat guys like in heaven
like later on and they kind of like they
they kind of go back to that like in the
in the sequel
as well like that whole every character
that's in heaven like
saying for the other characters to like
come join them in heaven it's just like
really really funny i thought that was
like actually a nice touch yeah that's
probably um that probably wraps up the
first movie then right
yeah i'm trying to think if there's like
something else that i wanted to like say
about it like i said it's pretty much
it's a ridiculous
it's a bad movie but it knows it's bad
um
also there's like i couldn't but but
it's the kind of bad where you're not
really sure if they meant that to be bad
or funny on purpose or not you know what
i mean like the although the main
example is that of that is that jonbenet
ramsay joke yeah that that character
made one time
and then she made it another time and
then they [ __ ] it up and then like
somebody else tried to say the same
thing but [ __ ] it up and said like
nobody laughed and i was like well
did they just like make that joke twice
and like forget to edit the other one
out or was that the joke that then that
it was like i think that was the joke
that they made the joke yeah here's my
take on it
[Laughter]
it's
kind of like velociraptor all right
philosophical philosophers yeah uh
they're they're going for that kind of
tone
there are
flashes of brilliance in this movie some
of this shit's [ __ ] really funny
other stuff doesn't quite land
um
it's like the
quality is a little bit uneven it
some [ __ ] but like they're bragging that
they did it for 3 500 bucks so they
didn't have much money thank you camp
guy it needed to be some things needed
to be kind of like
tweaked and re-shot re-edited
so it was uniformly funny throughout the
entire goddamn thing which is what you
have and it's short it's only like an
hour long what's what does it even like
90 minutes velocipaster beats it because
philosopher is [ __ ] uniformly [ __ ]
funny through the whole goddamn thing
okay
and very witty a lot of the [ __ ] that
velocipastor does is just due to the
writing and the way they filmed it okay
this does it that same thing but maybe
only about half the time yeah it's like
spottier it's spottier okay
but i command it you know i mean it was
it was an entertaining movie i watched
through the whole thing i had it i was
laughing okay
um i liked the characters [ __ ] there
were certain scenes that stood out it
you know my time wasn't wasted and they
got their [ __ ] 3 500 worth although
oscar perez said why do you guys waste
your time with this chunk
because it's funny it's funny it's
entertaining it's funny this wasn't as
funny as velocipaster like i said it was
it was much spottier but it did have its
moments periods man [ __ ] watch
velocipaster that [ __ ] is a [ __ ]
masterpiece
and it's
just gotta see it you'll understand it i
mean that's the thing i like
all kind of movies i like real highbrow
already farty movies and i like really
stupid
bad movies if they're bad in a
particular way if it's bad and it's just
boring they have to know what they're
doing then i'm not you know i'm not on
board with it but it's honestly i think
you learn more about filmmaking watching
bad movies then you do good ones yeah
because you see what not to do to be
honest with you so you're like oh yeah i
need to avoid that problem right there
and then
you'll run across movies that just have
no
money in them at all but they're [ __ ]
great and you have to figure out why is
that thing great yeah okay
the the thanks killing
the first one
is about half there
it's half great the other part of it is
just not bad but the other the other
half is
okay
yeah but had they tightened the edit up
got some of the script and some of the
scenes a little bit right maybe
rewritten it a little in a couple little
places and re-shot it again
it could have been up there with it
could have been up there with [ __ ]
velocipaster but it has to uniformly be
hilarious hilarious through every scene
and it this wasn't hilarious in every
scene it might have been funny but not
hilarious
and it did have some [ __ ] that was
hilarious because like i said the whole
part was like the turkey wearing the
dad's face and like everyone just like
pretending that that was her dad i mean
that was like pretty funny that dude
dying and him was seeing his fat
boyfriend that was awesome come on man
come on come up to heaven man there's no
turkeys up here man
that's just like i i have a [ __ ]
wrong that was pretty funny yeah i have
dead but
um but yeah and oh and we forgot to say
too that turkey rapes a chick at one
point doesn't he rapes the [ __ ] chicks
yeah yeah yeah that was good that was
good too i thought it was funny it
wasn't hilarious but it was funny yeah
yeah and then and the thing were them
with the guy like pulling over and
wanting to like have sex that's [ __ ]
pretty that was also pretty funny so so
you know i'm gonna give credit where
credit is due they've been 3 500 bucks
they made an entertaining movie that
half the time was [ __ ] funny real
funny hilarious oh and also in 2013 they
did a musical version of this because of
course they did yeah um and it actually
showed at the orlando fringe festival
okay but um
i you know obviously i didn't see it
okay now this is the second one
all right the second one when it starts
off first of all you production value is
[ __ ] way higher well the second one
they actually raised money on
kickstarter and they got like i think a
hundred and twelve thousand dollars it
looks
good especially in the beginning like
what the [ __ ] is going on they kind of
opened the scope up into outer space and
[ __ ] they had some good outer space
scenes with the [ __ ] turkey in a
spaceship fighting an alien or talking
to an alien and then they got you know
[ __ ] dudes cleaning out
uh toxic waste trucks and they're all in
their [ __ ] biohazard
gear and
then
you're going into turkey's home with his
wife and he's kind of retired because
then [ __ ] he's got they got a two
he's not gonna be released he's pissed
and they got a kid named nibbla they got
a kid
he murdered his murderers his turkey
wife
gets his kid to [ __ ] agree with it
and weird [ __ ] and then they go [ __ ] it
and then a kid dies
and just it gets weirder and weirder and
then you find a [ __ ] fraggle this
[ __ ] cute little fraggle girl
living in a dumpster because she lost
her mind and and
and just crazy [ __ ] you know what i mean
this is yeah remember talking to a dude
in a wig who's dressed up like [ __ ]
like thomas jefferson and
it gets more and more bizarre you know
it involves other dimensions and aliens
and
yeah turkey this one is um drugs too it
got to be and then it has commercials
that [ __ ] crazy it has commercials and
magic great it has commercials in the
movie they're [ __ ] funny so some of
the commercials they had a couple
commercials well the guy in the wig
who's one of the only human characters
most of the rest are puppets but um he's
uncle donnie and he has invented
something called the pluck master 3000
right and uh it's something that kills
the turkey plucks the turkey stuffs the
turkey and cooks the turkey like all in
one all in one like
yeah 30 seconds that's right um but yeah
so there's that whole thing so why okay
so why there isn't a thanksgiving or
thanks killing two
is
in the context of thanks killing three
you have at the very beginning they show
like this little because at the end of
thanks killing the first one
um there's like a little coda where
there's all these family who i presume
is like the director and his family i'm
thinking that's who it was and they're
having thanksgiving dinner and then the
cooked turkey comes to life
and turkey's voice says i smell a sequel
and then flies at the camera and then it
says coming soon like thanksgiving
thanks killing in space
so there's a little preview where
there's like this really really cheap
ass looking
sci-fi like thing where it's puppets
and
all the ships are like made of turkey
basters right and uh so there's that and
it looks like super super cheap and then
there's like a meta thing where
thanks killing two was made but it was
so terrible that it's never gonna be
released
so part of the plot although not the
main plot
part of the plot of thanks killing three
is
um actually because all the copies of
thanks killing two have been destroyed
in this world like i said there's kind
of like there's somebody with a dump
truck and there's like toxic waste type
[ __ ]
and then so turkey
is trying to find the last remaining
copy
of thanks killing two and he's gonna
show it to everybody in the universe
right or just everybody on earth i can't
remember he's just gonna he's gonna like
hook it up to yeah it's very complicated
yeah and he's gonna hook it up and show
it to everybody and it's gonna like end
the world or something like that because
it's like the worst movie ever so
there's actually two intertwining plots
which
you really kind of have to
this is like the crazy [ __ ] ever yeah a
lot of the [ __ ] they're making up as
they go along yeah well i think the
thing is because they had the turkey
puppet
and apparently like whoever like the
crew that's working on this movie are
really into puppetry
so most of this most of the characters
in thanks killing three are puppets it's
like a kind of a cheap puppet thing
and um there's only a couple of human
characters so you have this whole thing
where the only remaining copy of
thanksgiving thanks killing two ends up
in this dumpster
and there's also the dumpster
there's a there's a puppet in there of
like trash that's alive
kind of like madame trash heap from
fraggle rock if you guys remember that
except he's kind of like a bag
and the puppet that's in there what's
her name yomi yeah yeah
she's like a little she's like a little
fraggle type character and she um can't
find her mind for some reason like never
explained her little like puppet mind
with a little its little brain with arms
going bye i'm going away
it's that kind of thing so like i said
just you know all right um big time so
there's like some serious like
hallucinogens yeah
you really you should
be high
or something didn't you see it it
it looks good though and it looks like
something out of a jen hamilton
hempstead movie jim heads yeah it's yeah
it's definitely um
spoofing on some jim henson stuff
because there was like some scenes in
there
that were out of the [ __ ] that were
very much like labyrinth or the dark
crystal
maybe because maybe they got that idea
because turkey the the puppet from the
first movie who's also in the third in
the second one um kind of looks like a
skeksis yeah um you know what i mean so
i could so i kind of feel like su so
this has a very much like
jim henson
vibe to it but yeah so this puppet
like so this puppet has the last
remaining copy even though she doesn't
really know what it is and she puts it
in her little backpack which by the way
has a cartoon cat character on it that
pops off at one point and then there's
like some weird animation like a kids
show for a second and that that never
returns so okay there's that and then
she meets the human character uncle
donnie who's like a pitch man who's
invented the pluck master 3000 and he's
dressed like colo like colonial america
all the time like with the powdered wig
like you have and [ __ ] like that
and also he lives with
his friend who is also dresses like a
colonial person all the time and
has a grandmother
is that his grandmother or his mom
i don't know who that is that's also a
puppet and it is the grossest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever it's like a grandma's mom
it's his mom yeah they call her grandma
though
she's like really old i don't really
remember but it doesn't matter but it's
a puppet
who is also it's like a grandma who is
also a rapper
and she's [ __ ] talking about sucking
dick all the time and [ __ ] and she's
always like she's like putting her smile
on her fingers
yeah like sticking her fingers in her
cooch and smelling them and stuff like
that it's pretty disgusting yeah um and
all the and she's always like
like rapping and that's all she ever
talks about and she kind of explains how
that happens like all of her cable got
shut off in the 90s except for b-e-t
okay is that what it was i think that i
think they kind of mentioned that so uh
so yes so she's always uh rapping and
all her raps are like completely gross
because she's like totally a hoe too
yeah um oh and if you stay like past the
credits there's also
uh i can't remember what her name was
flois flouis i think that was her name
yeah and um if you stick there's like a
music video and there's a really really
disgusting scene where she's talking
about [ __ ] a dude and like pulling
her diaper aside and stuff like that
it's pretty gross i'm just telling you
right now yeah um but yeah so
so there's that so those people are kind
of like involved with
uh finding the dvd but also trying to
look for this little puppet's
mind
and then at some point the only
remaining copy of thanks killing two
gets possessed
by
nibbla who is
um
turkey's
son
who he's also he's trying to make evil
but then he dies but then he's he like
takes his soul somewhere
it's very convoluted you can't you know
yeah it's like honestly i would i would
recommend watching this while high but
not well drunk because you will not be
able to keep track of what the [ __ ] is
going on right it's just like really
complicated oh and i forgot to mention
the giant
robot
muff
and the little worm
yeah the little bisexual worm rhonda
that's on his with a little mustache and
little googly eyes who like controls
muff but also they're like boyfriends i
don't like or something
they're like in love i guess i don't
really know
and they're from space oh and also
muff the robot
can um make a vortex out of his butt
yeah just yeah
i forgot about that
oh and also turkey and rhonda the worm
had sex at some point like while turkey
was on the moon yeah i forgot about that
too i don't really know this is all
stuff that was made you think i'm making
this up i am totally not making this up
they made this up
[Laughter]
and [ __ ] edited it together into
basically kind of like a long-form
hallucination there's a lot of special
effects in it and everything you know
yeah true it is a trip to watch
i gotta say i didn't like it as much as
the first one
i think the first one was just more pure
and more simple and crazy yeah i mean
the first one was basically just like a
slasher about a talking wisecracking
killer turkey yeah and it was kind of
easier to understand yeah the second one
you know thanks killing three yeah i was
just kind of like like the whole time
like it's funny but you're like what the
[ __ ] am i watching the tone kind of
changed too it's almost kind of like
mst 3000 netflix version not really the
movies that they're watching but you
know like the stuff happening in between
yeah it's like that it's almost like a
parody of a kids show yeah yeah and then
it almost seems to me and i think you
said this while we were watching it
because we were pretty sober when we
were watching this right we weren't
drunk i don't think i don't think we
drank well yeah i don't think we've
drunk overwatch which is a good thing
because like i said i wouldn't
i would have
no idea what the [ __ ] was going on but
um you know so
what it was was i think that maybe
like i said you had like a bunch of
puppeteers on the crew and they had made
a bunch of puppets that didn't have
anything to do with one another and that
they wanted to make like a parody of a
kid's show like something like i said
something for adult swim or something
like real surreal like that that you
know like stone like stoner guys in
their 20s would watch yeah um i i kind
of feel like they had that kind of thing
going but they're like well maybe we
should make that a sequel
to thanks killing yeah it's like it was
shoehorned into this project maybe well
maybe not because the first thanks
killing they did say like thanksgiving
in space like at the end like yeah you
know what i mean so maybe they kind of
knew what they were doing
was [ __ ] shoehorned in there too they
weren't in that space for a few minutes
at the very beginning that's true
and there was stuff from space like and
then it turns out i think it turns out
that the the fraggle i keep calling her
the freckle yo me the one whose mind was
gone it turns out she was an alien too
right or an interdimensional being or
something i don't really know yeah yeah
but she was also a puppet yeah because
the the prime ministers were based on
puppets on earth were based on actual
beings from another planet or another
dimension
trippy nonsense so she dies at some
point but then like you you could like
bring her back by sticking your hand up
her butt you know like you would a
puppet like because she was a puppet
right so you know what i mean so yeah um
i i can't imagine anyone in the history
of ever being as high as the people that
wrote this the people that wrote this
movie as high as they were when they
wrote this movie because
this uh yeah the whole time and i'm just
like i think it's some weird [ __ ] okay
but it's just kind of like
this i really really am not sure what it
and it's it's barely a horror movie
it's kind of more i don't even know what
i'd call it this kind of like reminded
me of the it had horror elements because
didn't that one colonial guy he got like
cut into pieces which was actually like
a pretty cool like effect that looked
really good but it's not
anything like the first one it is just
like a surreal
it's a trip movie yeah like a surreal
puppet show of kind of like yeah that
you would watch it on acid maybe
although maybe don't because i don't i
don't know if you'd understand it i
don't know what kind of like weird
flashbacks you have
it's just kind of like i don't know man
in a way i kind of like salute the
people that made it because i'm like i
can't believe that they [ __ ] actually
thought of this [ __ ] i think it you know
i think of course you know they they
crowd sourced it so uh it was done for
the fans yeah uh it's it's plenty long
uh it gives they're giving you
everything you know they're giving you a
lot for your money they're showing you a
lot of different stuff i don't know what
the fan reaction was maybe they liked it
i liked the first one better uh
just because of the purity of it
this one here the production value is a
lot higher the the special effects were
quite good the visuals were really good
yeah it almost kind of had some like
weird like new retro wave kind of like
videos and stuff inserted in there yeah
so i actually appreciated it it's just
uh
the story and that kind of humor just
now i didn't really get it that much you
know i maybe have to see it again i
don't know
yeah i mean i could probably like sit
through it it's a cult movie definitely
yeah you know i guess they forget you
know maybe people are watching it
and yeah and like i said i kind of feel
like
i mean it's really ambitious and i
really kind of like admired what they
did like i admired just they were just
kind of like we're just gonna make the
weirdest [ __ ] movie ever like yeah
throw that in there too it didn't really
have a coherent story
it was just to eat scenes of trippy [ __ ]
happen and it's kind of tied together it
kind of has a story yeah turkey was not
in it as much right
um
you know i i kind of he was and he was
still trying to get hold of like the dvd
but then you know later the dvd got
possessed by his son's soul for whatever
reason so they were trying to get that
back so he was actually in it because he
did have a goal in it but
most of the main stuff was about was
about the the fraggle puppet okay so
you're saying it had a story
sort it well i really couldn't follow it
well it had a story in the sense that
a couple of the characters did have
like a goal
you know what i mean
uh you forget all that though you do
that's well that's what i mean because
it just kind of go oh and i forgot to
mention too i totally forgot this
there's so much stuff going on in this
movie you guys that i totally forgot one
i forgot to mention that the two
colonial guys were their dream was to
open a theme park called thanksgiving
land so there was that um also i forgot
to mention wise turkey
who was this inter-dimensional
this was very jim hensony this part this
this inter-dimensional like wise turkey
that came there like a gandalf type
character but but a turkey i kind of
forgot about that guy and uh he comes
there and gives like five minutes of
exposition about evil turkey who was
like the regular turkey from the first
one and like kind of gives a whole thing
and it was just kind of like this lord
of the rings like quest kind of thing
this is all over the place there's just
all kind of like crazy [ __ ] in here and
um and it's a puppet show it's supposed
to be crazy as [ __ ] yeah like and like i
said because pretty much there are
two human characters i think just the
two guys right yeah i think everything
everybody else is a puppet yeah i think
so a puppet or someone in a costume
so
yeah it's pretty crazy honestly i think
i don't know i think people are more
kind of like
are more into like that kind of [ __ ]
nowadays because like i said there's a
whole like subculture of
just weird surreal cartoons and [ __ ]
like that i would have liked to have
seen these guys who did all this
puppetry
do a different project that was a little
bit more
coherent and a little more
you know
something that jim henson would actually
do
yeah you know what i mean i think it'd
be good i don't think it i don't think
it blended too well with the
thanksgiving
concept i would like to see them do
their own thing like they're
you know someone lines a little
labyrinth or some [ __ ] like that they'd
probably be pretty good
yeah because it seemed like this wanted
to be labyrinth yeah
or the dark crystal or something like
that right but then
on acid and also with the killer turkey
right you know what i mean so there was
there were scripts there was a lot of
ideas in here yeah it was it is fun and
like i said the less kind of i don't
know i was gonna like bring up the whole
rapping grandma thing again too but
man that was so gross that but it was so
gross looking yeah and like just like
the [ __ ] that she said yeah and it's
like if you watch like toward the video
like the video of hers that's after the
credits
um she had like a wheelchair and one of
the stickers on the wheelchair said
gilfin ain't easy
and i was just kind of like
it was like it was so nasty it's like
it's not that i'm like averse to like
old people having sex i will say she
want old people but that was and she
wasn't a real person she was a puppet
yeah yeah and it's just like a really
really disgusting and just like she says
like disgusting [ __ ] all the time
um i got the oxygen thing on her nose
and [ __ ] yeah it was just like so it's
so so gross and it's just like i don't
know it was just like really gross but
uh yeah
somebody says uh review enter the void
center for puppetry arts in atlanta is a
great place to take your kids
okay
uh troll two sonny said
there's a children's cartoon right now
called trolls and it has a bunch of
troll dolls and lots of lsd references
yeah i haven't seen the cartoon but i've
seen like clips of it and wasn't that
didn't they make like a
couple movies i think like trolls world
tour and all that kind of stuff because
i remember seeing trailers for that
but um
yeah so
this okay so seriously these are kind of
two completely different movies so
i don't really we watched them just one
after the other
um
i had a break in between maybe it would
have been yeah i was gonna say i think
it's probably better because they're
completely different vibes yeah so if
you're in like kind of like a comedy
horror slasher gory
stupid
kind of
thing then watch the first one if you
just want to see something that's like
one of the most bizarre [ __ ] things
you've ever seen and you just want to
like get high and watch it then watch
the then watch thanks killing three i
don't really i mean you don't really
have to watch one after the other
because they don't really have much to
do with other than the killer turkey
there's really not much to do with any
and the sec and the second one is like
so batshit that
it really doesn't have much narrative
like through line with the first one so
it's like you don't really have to have
like seen either one but yeah they're
both worth watching if you like this
kind of bad movies or if you yeah if you
if you like if you're like oscar perez
was saying that
we got to like waste our time on it but
there's
like i said there's a certain kind of
appreciation that i have
for really shitty movies yeah but i have
to be in the right mood though you know
what i mean i like i was like everything
i like low brow stuff i like highbrow
stuff but it depends on what mood i'm in
and um
and and i don't like all bad movies just
for the sake of being bad movies either
like i said it has to still be
entertaining yeah and um you know and
the first one had enough stuff in it
that was entertaining and the second one
was just so [ __ ] crazy that i
couldn't believe like what i was looking
at yeah so i was just kind of like i
gotta wait and see what happens next
because uh okay because it was that
whole uh issue yeah so uh you know
you done talking yeah oh okay
turkey the 13th yeah
like i said first one wasn't bad i liked
i enjoyed the second one i it i think it
had script problems
coherency of it for me it was a little
difficult to follow
had good visuals though uh certain parts
of it were like oh come on a little bit
over the top
but that was that's what this movie was
trying to do
um although when it comes to be
the king of all
bad movies
no it's still going to be velocipaster
that one's a [ __ ] masterpiece
and if you haven't seen philosophy
pastor i'd recommend seeing that first
see velocity faster i think the thing i
think the thing i know we bring that
movie up a lot but the thing that makes
velocipaster work too is that
philosopher is very good-natured yeah
it's yeah it makes sense and all the
characters are kind of like good nature
yeah i kind of feel like what happens
with a lot of bad like people that make
bad movies on purpose is that they're a
little bit like kind of mean-spirited or
they're or they're supposed to be like
oh we're just gonna do like this
shocking [ __ ] for this yeah it's
shocking they're trying to be edge lord
yeah and this move these movies do that
yeah the first one kind of did do that
yeah um oh well the second one did too
um where
they're just like trying to see what
they can get away but we're gonna do
like the grossest [ __ ] or we're gonna
say this shocking [ __ ] or whatever which
like i said you know can be funny to an
extent but after a while you're just
getting like oh were you just being edge
lordy um i didn't like velocipaster was
not trying to be edge lordy it was just
kind of like a good natured yeah
velocipaster is a 1980s style kung fu
movie
about a priest with a dude and a
dinosaur he's gonna turn into a dinosaur
to understand it and it makes total
[ __ ] sense it's great it's a great
movie yeah yeah pat hatfield said
earlier that he said you're describing
what's happening in the movie and i'm
going what
yeah that's pretty much what i was
saying too like i said it sounds like
i'm making it up and i'm totally not i
promise everything that i said is
actually
i think they achieved
what they set out to do it's just it was
not my bag 100 you know what i'm talking
about yeah that's all yeah but like i
said i admire their um
their ambition because that was it was
something else yeah and pat hadfield
also said the grandma characters turned
me off the movie yeah yeah uh i i could
see why like i get that they were
parodying because remember there was a
time when was this was it 90s or 2000s
where like oh we're gonna put an old
person in the movie that raps isn't that
the funniest thing ever i kind of feel
like they did that in several movies
uh to the point where it became to see
this yeah so like in comedies to the
point where it's just like oh yeah okay
hilarious you know what i mean
look it's like seen it so maybe it was
funny the first time i don't remember
who did it the first time but i kind of
feel like then other movies would do it
it's like look an old lady rapping isn't
that hilarious and uh so i kind of feel
like they were parodying that
uh so i get that but
i don't know it was just like and i get
that like people are grossed out by like
you know old people in sexual situations
and i get that but i don't know i just
kind of felt like it was pretty [ __ ]
gross like even for me
like it's a pretty gross character but
uh i mean i don't know there was some
funny [ __ ] in there but
i don't know there's
i i just i'm very like i don't know how
i feel about it because it's just like a
weird-ass movie i'll probably like watch
it again at some point and see
how i feel about it but you know
there's not a lot of thanksgiving
themed
oh
okay okay
there's not a lot of thanksgiving themed
horror movies out there
so
if you want to like
you know
see one then
uh i also actually i did like i said i
did one for a movie called pilgrim which
is on hulu i think that's the only place
you can watch it but i'm gonna put that
up on thursday that was actually not bad
i uh quite enjoyed that a lot but yeah
so
uh yeah grandpa's hammer yeah the
wedding singer that was one of them and
i remember liking that movie otherwise
but
that trope got like old really fast just
kind of like those
comedies and the i guess it was the
2000s where it's gonna like we're going
to have like talking animals it's a
talking cat it's a talking dog it's a
talking baby
stop it shit's not funny but uh yeah all
right so
we're gonna go now
and uh so tomorrow
is gonna be our wednesday night regular
episode doing a thanksgiving special all
old old west ghost stories okay yeah so
if anybody like knows of any that you
want me to cover because i found a [ __ ]
ton there are so many like ghost stories
of the old west thank you aaron e turkey
donation thankful for all the
entertainment oh thank you so much
uh but yeah so if anybody has any old
west ghost stories like you know maybe
like send me a message on facebook or
something like that like before
we go on tomorrow and i'll see if i can
put because i found this really cool
website that had like 50 bajillion
different
old west ghost stories so i tried to
pick out some like a good variety of
them but if there's any that you want to
hear me talk about then let me know
uh as soon as possible
uh but yeah so we will see you guys
again
tomorrow evening at 5 p.m eastern
standard time thanks for hanging out
with us thanks for all of your super
chats and we'll see you tomorrow
bye